[Music]
Whitney is with us in Atlanta Georgia
hey Whitney what's up in your world
oh are you better than I deserve
how can I help I'll just feel exciting
this talk to you um so I'm 28 years old
I lovely five months into my debt
snowball how do i say motivated to pay
off his last eighty two thousand dollars
worth of student loan debt how bad do
you want to be wealthy why do you want
to be well why do you want to be well
well well my mom is very bad with
finances she lost her home and lost
everything basically her 401k she's ran
first I just don't want to feel like
that one of the middle there so you had
an anti mentor I've seen what financial
crap looks like I don't want any that's
a good that's a good motivation okay why
else do you want to be wealthy I just I
just don't like the burden of only other
people so far like its it lies why is
that a burden just like how you felt
like you you're a slave to the lender
you know I just I don't like being
around people that I owe you know you
give it your friends money and I don't
you know no I think you're on to
something and so I think what I'm
looking for here and I'm asking these
questions that you already know the
answers to and I certainly know the
answers to them but you know you've got
to have a big enough why or you run out
of steam on any goal yeah I feel you
need to put money to make like two
little signs or three little signs for
your refrigerator one is I don't want to
be in the same situation my mom was in
I've watched how it destroyed her life
and I don't wanna be that way some kind
of a little saying that you give
yourself right the anti mentor sign and
then you know you need to think about
and put into words what it's going to
feel like when you don't have the burden
you said remember the birth that was a
word you used when you don't have that
yoke around your neck when I don't have
this the sense of fear that dad gives me
instead
I've got peace financial peace to words
that don't go together right and you
know I won't know how that's gonna feel
and when you keep those signs the
positive of how you're gonna feel when
you get there how awesome it's going to
be because you're gonna be able to dot
dot dot travel the world give more
generously fund someone's education may
be yours I don't know I mean what is it
you want to do when you get there if I
handed you a million dollars today and
you had no other debt and you could just
start enjoying your wealth what would
that look like and write that stuff down
that's why you're fighting that's what
you're fighting for okay if you get a
real clear high definition as Chris
Hogan calls it goal of your future you
put your dreams in hi-def then you look
at that eighty two thousand and you're
going you're freaking standing between
me and my hi-def dream you're going down
okay
you see what I'm doing okay you gotta
have a reason just getting rid of the
debt for getting rid of the debt is not
enough getting rid of the debt so that I
don't I don't have that that sense of
fear and loss like mom had that's a good
reason getting rid of the debt so that I
don't have a sense of burden and I can
do dot dot dot with some wealth that I
have that's a good reason and you'll
keep fighting for those but you gotta
have something worth fighting for and if
you got a big enough why you can run
through a brick wall and if you get a
big enough why you don't care what
people say because people always have an
opinion and people are stupid and you
can't worry about what people say
because most people look good and are
broke and you really if you're worried
about what people say that means you
don't have a big enough why when I went
broke I was one of the benefits of me
going broke
I held hunger care what people think
it's kind of sad I really don't care at
all
it's I should care a little bit but I
don't care at all my wife is like you
should actually no I don't I just don't
care it's I mean listen I'm doing my
thing this is where we're going I got a
really big thing I'm doing and to the
extent you're not going to help with
that or you're an impediment to that I'm
just going to run over your butt you
know because this is what we're doing
and when you don't care what people
think then and you know
I don't care what you think about what I
Drive I Drive what I Drive cuz I want to
drive it I enjoy that car I didn't buy
it for you about it from me you know and
that's different then I bought this to
impress my friends or somebody at a
stoplight it'll think I'm cool you know
give me thumbs up at a stoplight and
you're in high school well that's kind
of cool but for about what half a second
I'm preciate it that's nice but I'm buy
a car for you you don't care what people
think when you got a big enough goal
when you got a big enough y and you can
plow through all the naysayers they
don't care about your health they don't
care about your marriage
they don't care about your kids they
don't care about your career and they
certainly don't care about your
financial goals so get you a big old why
it'll keep you going a long time this is
the Dave Ramsey show